NICK FURY
Captain Rambeau...
...what the hell are you doing?
MONICA RAMBEAU
Entering the jump point perimeter.
I'm gonna get you some readings, Fury.
NICK FURY
What...
MONICA RAMBEAU
Hello?
NICK FURY
Monica?
MONICA RAMBEAU
Hello?
[Screaming]
KAMALA KHAN
Oh my God, oh my God,
oh my God, oh my God!
NICK FURY
Captain Rambeau?
KAMALA KHAN
[Screaming] Please help!
Nick Fury! Hi!
Is this an Avengers test?
NICK FURY
Where's Captain Rambeau?
♫ ["Intergalactic"
by Beastie Boys playing] ♫
MONICA RAMBEAU
Wait a minute!
CAROL DANVERS
What the...
♫ Well, now,
don't you tell me to smile ♫
♫ You stick around
I'll make it worth your while ♫
MONICA RAMBEAU
Hi.
NICK FURY
We're looking for Kamala Khan.
KAMALA KHAN
[Gasps] Did I get in?
MONICA RAMBEAU
Okay so, our powers are entangled.
I can manipulate light
energy and you...
KAMALA KHAN
I can totally show you!
ALL
No!
Kamala!
CAROL DANVERS
Ugh! Not again!
Hi.
MUNEEBA KHAN
Where is our daughter?
MONICA RAMBEAU
Wherever you were.
KAMALA KHAN
Oh my God!
♪♪
NICK FURY
Shields up!
[Screaming]
KAMALA KHAN
We're a team?
MONICA RAMBEAU
Oh, no, no, no, we're not a team.
CAROL DANVERS
We're not a team.
[Kamala gasps]
♪♪
♫ Do it ♫